but
um
do you think that women are using this
as a form of birth control in a way i
was going to say yeah i was going to ask
that question is is it because they've
made a poor decision on the certain male
and then they thought right i can't be
having his kid specifically yeah i mean
maybe the first time but the second
third time forty percent
no i mean it's a business is it does it
build up
do you do you guys know the history of
uh like why abortion was created and
what not
in the us in the us i don't know about
here but in the end oh in the u.s
um i learned this from pearl but the
creator of was it planned parenthood the
creative planned parenthood
overall the goal was to
essentially
decrease the population of
the black community so that was the goal
like if we
if we have abortion if we have this
option to where people can
essentially kill off the baby
let's give it to the communities that
are less fortunate and
the less fortunate communities were the
black communities and so it was just
like a cycle so that's essentially
why
planned parenthood was yeah she was a
known eugenicist
and and they created marketing plans um
like specifically for minority
neighborhoods and then even today 80
percent of planned parenthood's in the
us are in black communities and the
black population would be double today
if there wasn't abortion and and there's
a 50 birth rate so 50 of all pregnancies
in the black community end in abortion
yeah so it's kind of messed up because
that was her goal and she's literally
achieving it today
i mean there's a lot of issues
with society
you know around
parenthood planned parenthood right so i
wouldn't
i mean
would it could anyone really say like
yeah i wish there was like more of a
certain kind of person based on
like the idea that so you said that
there would be like twice as many
african-americans et cetera yeah today
was
i'm in favor of like population control
basically oh you're in favor of
population control like planned
parenthood in a sense
yeah as in like
no but you can have two two competing
ideologies right you can have which what
seems to be the conservative ideology
which is like just have kids have ten
whatever hustle see you know
make ends meet if they survive one of
them could be lil wayne you know etc
that's cool okay okay now keep going
don't support single mothers don't
support anyone anything you do
you you pay the direct consequence of it
and that's that's it and society has to
pay that as well but that's it really
that's exactly what we say yeah that's
because that's why i see the
conservative perspective as when you
boil it down to what it is that's what
it seems like because conservatives
donate more than liberals
but continue continuing i'm not talking
about like altruism or donation okay
okay but um and then there's the other
perspective which it's more lefty um
but the idea of like we have to kind of
try and
support a manager population in a way is
to have you know
manage the population growth in some way
you know especially for an advanced
economy if you have all these like
luxuries like you know healthcare all
these tech tech goods food everything
has to be carefully managed so and and
the costs have to be managed and the
quality of living has to be managed sure
so you're for abortion
yeah i've said that yeah so so you can't
just have anyone having any kids because
then all those people go into this
carefully controlled and highly advanced
system and could cause all kinds of
habits so i just have a question you
think
who should manage it
who should manage the population
it would have to go through like common
sense stuff i don't think it's an
individual but there'll be certain
policies that are aimed at supporting
responsible families parenthood et
cetera okay so so you think like
politicians in a sense should control
the population
no no like based on the laws that
they're passing you definitely said
policies yeah politicians control
policies but essentially they do using
your words
using your words if we were to go along
with uh so so in this case the
eugenicists like she was helping with
policy
and that did control a population you
think that was a net good yeah okay no
that that that's not great the history
of it but obviously you know but the
abortion process wasn't that
for society
in the long run yeah the ability to have
abortions
i mean now the abilities have abortions
the ability to wipe out 50 of a
potential population yeah to control
population abortion yeah yeah by
controlling do you think controlling the
black population in the us isn't that
good
well that's that's that well you can
control any population right that's what
human beings will be doing all the time
so the idea of whether it's good or bad
is is irrelevant it's like is it good if
i punch you in the face people have been
doing that
you know the idea of
the population is being controlled
anyway okay even if you went through all
right-wing policies you're still being
me saying you can't have an abortion
it's still controlled
a specific example
if you said even if you go through right
wing policies
the population is being controlled
anyway can i have a specific example
well if you were to say
well the what um what was said before
about having eight to nine kids and if
one of them turns out to be lil wayne
allowing these kids to go out in the
world and deal with who's who said lil
wayne sorry
one of them could be successful okay
then
they'll be controlled by the environment
which in this that in this day and age
will be controlled by the policies you
make you know we're not in the jungle
anymore right so these policies have
direct influences you don't think people
have individual decisions and choices
and like a mind of their own absolutely
but we also function as a society okay
so the kind of food you give people
access to has an effect of the
population it kind of influences the
kind of procedures you know allowing
them access to abortion or have an
impact not allowing them access to
access to abortion has an impact okay so
you're being controlled anyway the idea
that like we can all just do what we
want okay so so you know i i have a big
family right and maybe i'm just curious
how how am i being controlled
like i'm i'm in the west like how am i
being controlled you're controlled by a
larger society how um the kind of
schools you go to the kind of people you
have access to um you have to pay for
university the kind of jobs you have
access to when you graduate so so if i
if i
in 2022 i'm making a choice whether i
have sex or i don't have sex right
um
how how am i being controlled if when i
get to choose whether or not i use
protection or i don't use protection
how is a policy controlling me
well it controls the outcomes if
anything happens
okay but at the end of the day i have a
choice to be abstinent or not be
abstinent
yeah you have a choice but right yeah
right so i just don't understand how i'm
being controlled
you're being controlled in a large on a
larger level so your individual choice
is still there but the fact is what the
outcome of whatever you do that and the
outcome must be decided by society if
you have a child you need a midwife you
need you know child mortality was really
high without all this tech so if you
could so by having
hospitals and medical professionals
we're talking about policies so like i
think you're moving a little bit here
we're talking because now you're talking
about technological advancement we're
talking about policies
yeah are you saying like uh that that
they won't be able to be
um
they're kind of getting suppressed or or
you know stop because they're not able
to have the same opportunities that a
smaller family would have or they
wouldn't have like financial obligations
because the family is much much bigger
that would stop them from having certain
opportunities to go into certain schools
going
to certain places in society because
there's
it's too big a family and the
affordability would bring him into a low
class of citizen as per say
i'm just saying that these policies have
a direct impact on
on
the outcomes so so would you agree that
these policies have an impact like if
you say people can do this and not do
this that will have an impact on how
society is a large tends to like evolve
growth i think taking away
consequences has a negative impact and
i'm all for
making people face the consequences of
their own choices
so you want to control
no i don't i don't know it's lack of
control actually it's no government
control it's everyone pick what they
want to pick but deal with the
consequences
so if i want to be abstinent till i'm
married
that's that's one choice if i want to
have a kid out of wedlock that's another
choice but the government shouldn't bail
me out of my bad choices
that's like saying if you punch somebody
and they punch you back it's like why'd
you punch me back that's a consequence
for your actions yeah
i understand that approach but i'm not
governed by policy can i just say add to
that
that's not governed by policy
the consequence so if you punch me and
i'll punch you back it wasn't governed
by policy that was a choice that you
made and it had consequences okay
so so having sex that's a choice and
there's consequence yeah and so if you
choose to have you can't afford to have
sex and don't have sex but i i feel like
what's always missing from the
conservative viewpoint is this idea of
like
it's very ideol ideological of like yeah
like everyone should have to do what
they want and you know the outcome will
just happen in natural selection but it
doesn't work out like that like if you
say for example you don't support
single moms then we already know that
people from those backgrounds are
disproportionately likely to end you
know
less successful problem mental health
issues those people then go into society
and cause other issues so republicans or
conservatives complain a lot about crime
and this and that but then you also say
less not less less support the most
vulnerable households less
because you know free choice let them
face consequences it just seems like i
think i think right now women are
incentivized to leave
they're given an incentive to take the
father out of the home because they are
literally paid to do it if you pay
someone to like if you pay someone to
take the dad out of the choi out of the
home
more people are going to do it that's
just common sense
so i to me if you took that away there
would be an incentive to keep families
together which is better for the kids
and the kids would have better outcomes
yeah that's true
they are incentivized to do that i think
the policies need a lot of work i'm not
saying the policies right now are great
i think
i think society has to be controlled
um or managed in a way as to ensure the
most positive outcomes for the maximum
amount of people that's not to say that
like the policies we have now are good
so i do believe in right to choose but i
also believe in financial
abortion right equality i agree with
yeah and i think i think that that's
balanced isn't it yeah because then you
take away the incentive to abuse a
system that supports vulnerable people
actually i don't believe in abortion i
don't agree with you
but but i do agree if we're gonna have
abortion legalized there should be a
financial abortion yeah there has to be
a balance right and and i'm i'm not
saying the abortion thing is like the
only thing you could also ban abortion
but then there also has to be a balance
in terms of like making that work for
society or else you could create kind of
a pathway for people you've seen with
marginalized communities where you know
you systematically ban them from certain
higher education certain foods and then
you have a market or market abortion to
them you know that too yeah stuff like
that all these all these things that you
can do that you can directly impact a
population of people i'm just saying
that happens to everyone on a larger
scale
and having that discussion around
policies and the real life impact is
like important